Dress the way you want to address.
It's not their problem,
it's the guy's problem.
Let's correct the guys rather than us.
Right.
I love that.
But there's a lot of guys that haven't been corrected yet who are going to
hassle you and follow you in the parking lot.
That's the problem.
Those guys aren't woke once.
Everyone's all,
whoa.
It will be great.
Dangerous word to use.
I feel like people are gonna mock it in the future.
Woke woke.
Yeah.
I feel like using woke now like unironically super slippery.
I see a trap coming.
You do.
Did you Jitsu practitioner in me.
It's like I don't like this move and this is a,
I know where this leads
me.
Right?
That's how I feel.
Yeah,
I see that woke thing.
I'm like,
what are you woke?
What the fuck does that even mean?
I woke up,
you woke up,
what do you 12 well he comes from my 16 year old.
So yeah,
it's kids today.
But what does work mean?
It means your brain is open.
You're open to stuff.
Your problem is,
there's no real quantification.
There's no real,
there's no test you tank to show that if you're woke.
Right.
Like if you want to be a mathematician,
you have to fucking show that you know how to do math.
The professor say check your work.
Like you get through like yes,
congratulations Tom Papa.
Yeah,
you are a mathematician.
You know phd in mathematics says right here on the paper and you're like,
God damn it,
I'm going to put that shit on my walls.
You understand?
I know how this stuff works.
Yeah.
But wokeness anybody can claim to be a master of wokeness.
It's like Kung Fu without fighting.
It's very dangerous.
No one's defined what's woke and what's preposterous.
No one's defined what's,
what's just not racist and not success and not homophobic,
but open minded and aware of the,
the,
the failings and the misgivings of all sides with no bias.
Right.
Is that what,
cause it doesn't seem like it is,
isn't that woke?
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I think you just described what I thought it was.
I would like that,
but too many people could jump in.
There's no,
there's no real clear understanding of like what makes in constitutes someone
being walked like,
yeah.
How many of those boxes do you have to check where it was like a lap.
Tom Papa had a woke academy and you took these people through.
It would just be,
do you like bread or not like bread claiming wokeness super slippery.
What's his Jamie?
62 New York Times magazine already woke
crazy.
God Dig it.
Look,
if you're woke,
you dig it.
Oh,
that's the perfect definition right there.
[inaudible] if you're woke,
you dig it.
That is insane.
That was my fox man.
And you were copying my taste and grit.
What?
Don't jump salty on me.
Whoa.
Look,
how have they talked back then?
They were trying to talk people into talking to way that made them seem more
interesting.
I'm going to say it the way I would say if I lived back then,
hey,
could you make it bigger so I can see it?
You'll be the guy on the left.
No scrolling.
So we could read the comments.
Yeah.
What he's saying up top.
That was,
that was my facts man.
And you were counting Matt tasting,
grace and grit.
So how would you say that now?
Um,
that was my fox man comping my tasting grid.
Of course it's girl.
That's my girl.
That's what he's saying.
No,
that's what they said.
Oh,
would you use,
what words would you use today?
Yeah.
He would say,
the fuck are you doing with my girlfriend,
dickhead?
And he said,
don't jump salty on me.
I would say,
hey,
we're cool.
No worries.
Stop being such a bitch.
It's all good.
Yeah.
And then it'd be like,
what?
Oh,
someone's a badge.
And then next thing you know,
people be hitting each other.
That's a darkness.
No men.
Who are these two gentlemen to the risers?
The,
it says no Webster.
I think that might be like Webster's dictionary.
I Peter one Peter in the,
in the dictionary.
That's squirly if you feel like the letters are all blurred.
Right.
I love that.
If you're woke,
you'll dig it.
Yeah.
If you're woke,
you dig it.
That's,
that sums it up,
man.
If you're woke,
you dig it.
And after,
how'd you find this Jamie?
Come back to that.
Uh,
it's like know your meme.
Oh Wow.
So the meme of the word woke?
Yeah.
Wow.
Look at that little image though.
Scroll Bar Graphs where we see that again,
that's so strange.
Like I'm batch,
if that was contemporary,
like if that was your world,
like imagine if hipsters all of a sudden started wearing tails.
So their jackets,
they just decided this is the next level or the bow ties and those tails.
It wouldn't be surprising cause that's all about just doing what you guys don't
do.
So I'm going to Hales.
What a weird look though.
It is.
That is so weird.
That's a look that like,
okay,
so like the guy in the center,
it's like those two guys,
both of the guys in the center.
Those guys will fly today.
Oh totally.
The guy in the left that looks like he's dressed like he's a,
that looks like me on the road.
Yeah.
I mean,
but he looks like,
look,
he's in a Quentin Tarantino movie or something.
It looks like he's reservoir dog.
That's totally normal.
The matrix black suit tie that'll door.
I can go to any restaurant anywhere and no one would even bat an eye like,
Oh sir,
can I help you?
Boom.
Right in image the guy next to him.
But those two guys on the ends,
like what in the fuck are they?
He's got a coat with towels.
Yeah.
And those pants that are like flat across your crotch where it looks like give
no privates.
Here's good way to look at it.
Imagine if you're dating a gal and a prepass is going to come over and you're
like,
you're really gonna love my dad.
He's an amazing guy.
He's real old school.
Jack comes up with a dress like that with coattails and you start feeling like
you're like,
you're in that movie.
Get Out.
He's gay.
He's got a handlebar mustache.
He's got tails.
Yeah.
Weird weird pants with the go into funny shoes.
You see,
get out.
Yeah.
I finally watched it during sober October.
Oh,
you did fucking fantastic.
Yeah,
but that's what you'd be thinking if that guy was dressed like that,
that the daughter was going to lead you to something.
And you have to run for your life.
But it is weird how like that suit has lasted.
Yeah,
a long time.
Well,
this was 1960 so I'm assuming that it was mocking the style of old,
so by the time 1960 rolled around,
the guys in the middle,
we're dressed contemporary,
but the guys at the end,
like making fun of people the way they used to dress kind of in a way,
or at least that's what represents those people.
Yeah.
It just defines their time.
That guy was probably around the 18 hundreds and it's just one of the floors.
Other guys are,
do you know who those guys are?
I believe no.
Webster.
Webster Addiction.
That's why he's got the pen and he's scratching his head.
Is that guys putting out his slang?
His slang is making Webster's what the fuck?
He's like,
that's not how you really say it.
So it'd be like the urban dictionary,
like a w Jamie and I sometimes get confused.
We have to pull up the urban decks,
try and find out what the real word of a word means.
So let's pull up woke represented today.
You know what,
no disrespect,
no cultural appropriation intended.
The fact that it was invented actually in the 60s it was really weird.
It's just making a comeback,
looking around when I typed in,
like what does it work to see if there's anything,
if you dig it,
you will.
What's it saying were knowledgeable about your community in the world with the
willingness to access and critique systems of oppression?
Uh,
well that the ambulance parked the last Carl.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yes.
I mean for sure if it really is a system of oppression,
but how do we decide what's a system of oppression and what is sounds like any
Jordan Peterson,
weird human behavior
represents then what do you mean interact with each other on a grand scale?
I mean,
that's just like I,
there are some legitimate systems of oppression,
right?
Yeah.
For Real.
It's like figuring out which one it is.
Yeah.
Before,
but putting that and like,
that's what woke is like,
how do you do,
how do you define what the system's like?
Where does it,
where's the line get drawn?
Right,
right.
It's the line.
Hmm.
Like,
why do women,
uh,
kept certain jobs?
Why do men have short and jobs?
How much of that is because of influence?
How much of that is because of their choices?
How much of that it's just because of natural proclivities towards certain
things.
Well,
then you're talking about people that are coming after the hierarchy and if
they're coming up through the hierarchy,
who's to say that those people are in part of the problem?
I love Jordan Peterson.
The,
it's just like hammers.
Just,
well then what do you want?
What are you saying then?
Who are you?
What do,
what are you,
you,
you're buying into the hierarchy.
It's just love like the exasperations in his ways.
No,
but it's true.
It's like,
then this true,
but that woke definition was like,
oh,
I'm with you.
This is all about being nice and kind.
And then at the end it's about attacking.